California is the third
largest oil-producing
state in the country.
A lot of people
don't realize that.
When they think of
California, they think
of vineyards and Hollywood.
But we've been living with
oil and gas production
since the late 19th century.
Kern County is
really the epicenter
of oil production in
California, where about 80%
of our state's oil is produced.
NARRATOR: The Central Valley,
where half of Kern County lies,
produces 25% of America's food.
Oil and agriculture
have always had
a tenuous relationship here.
I make my living
on the surface.
They make their living below.
NARRATOR: Keith Gardiner and his
business partner, Holly King,
have farmed in Kern
County for 22 years,
right alongside big oil.
HOLLY KING: You have two owners
on the same piece of property,
one who owns the
minerals and the farmer
who owns the surface.
KEITH GARDINER: A land
man from an oil company
will call or come
out to your office
and say, hey, the
trucks are lined up.
We're gonna be in
there tomorrow.
We want to drill here and here.
Well, immediately,
you get into a fight.
You say, no, you're not.
Yes, we are.
No, you're not.
Well, we're gonna sue you.
And I'm just a
little guy, you know.
I can't stand to be
sued by an oil company.
So a lot of times, you
just acquiesce, say,
go ahead, you know.
I can't fight you.
We do have an
obligation to allow
them to access their minerals,
and we're OK with that.
We're not OK with
we can do anything
we want on your surface,
because we're the big guys.
NARRATOR: Like Earl
Tennant in West Virginia,
they have seen substantial
damage on their farm.
KEITH GARDINER: We noticed the
overall health of the trees
was not good.
We started testing the water,
and we found out that we
had a lot of high salts.
A lot of high chlorides.
And those are just the
death of almond trees.
We took out about 8,000 trees.
We suspected that billions
of barrels of saltwater
was getting injected
into our freshwater zone.
When you start taking our
trees out, it's a problem.